so with nothing really being revealed
about a vendor's for with the exception
of a promo photo that came out not too
long ago and if you missed that you can
check it out in the link above but with
the exception of that there's really
been a lot of mystery surrounding
Avengers for nothing official has
actually come out or been stated
regarding the movie with the exceptions
of Kevin Feige saying a few things here
and there not really given anything away
besides the fact that Avengers 4 is
going to wrap up the storylines for some
of the original Avengers but that's
nothing that we didn't all already know
but just because some things aren't
official doesn't exactly mean that we
don't know what's gonna happen for
example we all know that Avengers 4 is
going to use the quantum realm in some
way and I mean we all pretty much know
that they're going to use it to be
traveling through time and to different
realities and of course we have our
leaks it's really hard to know what's
real or what's not real with leaks but
just like anything if there's enough
people involved something's getting out
I've done a few videos recently on some
supposed popular leaks that have been
going around but lately I've been
getting a lot of questions about one
certain leak involving the Hulk and Hulk
smash in Avengers 4 you should take with
a grain of salt because you never know
if it's real or if it's just somebody
out there making something up for the
fun of it but this leak that many of you
have asked me to talk about is about the
Hulk wielding the Infinity Gauntlet in
Avengers 4 to answer some of your
questions yes I've heard this leak
before I just didn't really know where
it's stemmed from because all I heard
was it's from someone that was in
production went and leaked the plot
online I've seen multiple articles on it
I've seen a lot of videos on it and I've
actually seen it on reddit from a user
that has been quite reputable in the
past he said a lot of things about
Avengers infinity war that ended up
being true so you never really know it
could be true but a
again take it with a grain of salt so
this leak really falls into play with
the big main leak that is going around
right now that says the Avengers will
form their own Infinity Gauntlet and
they will go throughout time and
different realities collecting Infinity
stones of course this will be done using
Hank Pimm's quantum realm technology
that we will see in ant-man and the wasp
and this lines up really well with the
leaked photos that we've seen and the
leaked footage that we've seen of what
appears to be the Avengers well it
appears to be ant-man Tony Stark
Bruce Banner and Captain America back in
time to the events of the first Avengers
movie in the Battle of New York and then
it goes on to talk about many things
that were mentioned again in the main
link that's going around if you have not
heard this leak you can check out the
video I did on it in the link above but
this new leak adds to the story it says
that there is a big game changer with
the Hulk the person who leaked this goes
on to say finally the last thing I was
told is that the Hulk has a bit of an
arc in Avengers 4 and that he is the one
to wield to start gauntlet against
Thanos he then wraps it up by saying but
he ends up losing his arm in the process
not sure how so this is what has been
added to the current leak that we
already have and there's actually two
things that are being added here one is
that obviously the Hulk will be the one
to yield the Infinity Gauntlet
but two it's actually going to be Starks
Infinity Gauntlet Infinity Gauntlet that
Stark makes it was already highly
speculated that Tony Stark would form
his own Infinity Gauntlet but nothing
was officially leaked about it it was
only speculated now it appears to have
shown up in this leak there were some
other theories and speculations that if
they're going to alternate realities are
going back in time then they could just
go back to Ned of Lear and asking Eitri
to make them their own Infinity Gauntlet
but again according to this leak stark
makes his own which is extremely
possible I mean Tony's a genius he's a
master engineer he's a master at physics
he is a genius he's Tony Stark I mean
I've said it before but in
Iron Man 2 the guy creates an element he
literally makes a new element I'm sure
he could handle forging and Infinity
Gauntlet but we have to keep in mind
just how powerful the Infinity stones
are Thanos wielded the Infinity Gauntlet
all throughout infinity war whether he
just had one stone in it to son three or
four or five stones it doesn't matter he
will did it the whole entire movie but
if you notice he only seems to use one
stone or two stones at a time during all
these fight scenes and why is this I
personally think that it's because the
power of the Infinity stones combined is
even too powerful for the Infinity
Gauntlet to handle now I just want to
state that I think this is only for the
MCU it's obviously not the case in the
comics but if you think about it and you
look at the end of Avengers infinity
where it makes sense because Dallas's
gauntlet is destroyed at the end of an
infinity war I'm sure that O's could
just use the time stone to restore the
Infinity Gauntlet no big deal but it is
clear that using all the Infinity stones
at once is even too much for the
Infinity Gauntlet to handle yes it's
still intact but it really looks like
it's pretty much destroyed so Thor saw
this at the end of infinity war he was
right there when Thanos snapped his
fingers and when he asked him what he
did he's looking at the Infinity
Gauntlet he sees it destroyed and Thor
has a great knowledge of the Infinity
stones and their powers so as the
original Avengers unite for the first
time in a really long time
I'm sure Thor is gonna bring this up to
Tony Stark they'll all be going over the
planet of going to different realities
and jumping through time to collect all
the Infinity stones and then Tony's
gonna bring up forging his own Infinity
Gauntlet and then Thor's gonna issue a
warning that the Infinity Gauntlet is
way too powerful for a puny human to
wield and then I think that this is
where it's gonna land on the Hulk the
leek says that the Hulk is going to get
a lot of time in Avengers 4 which makes
sense because he didn't really get any
time an infinity war except for in the
beginning where he got the snot kicked
out of him and
we didn't see him for the rest of the
movie I mean maybe like half a second
here and there where he refuses to come
out but he wasn't in the rest of the
movie
it was banner of the whole time so him
getting more time in a vendor's for it
makes sense plus if they're worried
about none of them being able to handle
the power of the Infinity Gauntlet who
do you think they're gonna turn to fire
raging fire Thor might put up an
argument for it but ultimately I think
it would land on the Hulk voice
activation required banner welcome
strongest Avenger Oh what so this theory
stating that the Hulk will wield the
Infinity Gauntlet
in Avengers 4 I can buy it the angrier
the Hulk gets the stronger he gets and
can he even die there's a few times in
the comics where he dies but can he die
in the MCU and heck even one time in the
comics banner dies but the Hulk stays
alive but as far as the MCU is concerned
let's not forget about what banner says
in the first Avengers movie talked about
killing himself and he says in case you
needed to kill me but you can't I know I
tried I got low I didn't CNN so I put a
bullet in my mouth and the other guy
spit it out so you have the Incredible
Hulk who gets stronger the angrier he
gets and pretty much can't die and not
to mention that it looks like we might
get professor Hulk in Avengers for
judging by the leaked photos that have
been released which means that banner
and the Hulk will kind of be merged as
one character so you won't have to worry
about the Hulk just going crazy and
having no control because banner will be
there so there will be control so you
put those three things together and yeah
he's my choice to wield the Infinity
Gauntlet and as far as him losing his
arm goes I'm not too sure about that one
there's a lot of different ways that
they could take that the Infinity
Gauntlet could be just too struck from
the handle and somehow it chops his arm
off or Thanos
Soph his arm to get the Infinity
Gauntlet from him again there's so many
different ways they can take that and I
really just don't know which way they're
gonna go so I can't speculate too much
but one last question that I was asked
by many of you is that will the Hulk
actually wield to infinity gauntlets
like he does in the comics and my answer
to this is almost definitely not I don't
want to cross anything off it could
certainly happen but I just really don't
think it will the universe that the Hulk
wields these Infinity Gauntlet sin is
the Ultimates universe The Ultimates
universe is known for putting twists on
characters and plots and when the Hulk
yields these two Infinity Gauntlet there
are actually four stones each of the
gauntlets and that's because there are
eight stones in that universe so it
would be a major shake-up in Avengers 4
if they introduced three new Infinity
stones as incredibly cool I think it
would be to see that in the movie I just
really don't think it's gonna happen but
I can't see this supposedly playing out
on the big screen it does line up with
the other leak that was released not too
long ago and it would give the Hulk more
story time but again who knows what
these leaks take it with a grain of salt
as always it is my pleasure to report
these to you and give you my input on
them so do what you will with them only
time will tell I love all the questions
you guys asked me so if you have any be
sure to leave them in the comments below
or DM me on Twitter let me know what you
think about this leak would you be
excited to see this on screen if it
turns out to be true or would you like
to see it be taking a different way if
you don't mind hit that like button if
you enjoyed this video and subscribe to
my channel so you don't miss any new
Avengers for leaks as always thank you
so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you